passons à l'article 67 madame près villa
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre michelle collègues donc par ce
début d'examen du titre 6 relatif à la
protection judiciaire de l'environnement
là encore aucune disposition de ce texte
n'est réellement à la hauteur des enjeux
environnementaux auxquels nous faisons
face de nombreuses victimes attendaient
que la france reconnaisse le crime déco
side
pourtant il n'en sera rien après avoir
enterré la demande de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat en intégrant
une sorte de délit généralisée et non
pas un crime
le gouvernement et sa majorité ont créé
un dispositif qui suscitera des débats
juridiques infini le souhait était
pourtant de créer une législation pour
permettre de protéger les écosystèmes de
la dégradation et de la destruction afin
de garantir rien moins que
l'habitabilité de la planète
et si possible partout sur terre en
faisant porter la responsabilité
juridique et financière sur les hauteurs
des déprédations et en évitant
d'abandonner des populations entières
vivent dans des territoires pollués à
leur triste sort avec la rédaction
actuelle je crains fort que les
nombreuses victimes du chlordécone dans
nos beaux département de la guadeloupe
et de la martinique n'obtiendront ni
justice ni réparation ou faire tant ce
vous faites en sorte qu'il reste dans
notre pays un simple délit inscrit dans
la loi à ce titre la flanc la france
s'honorerait pourtant de ne pas attendre
que le changement juridique
interviennent au niveau international
pour avancer sur cette question
or la seule question qui vaille
avons-nous les lois adéquates
c'est à dire ah mais de permettre au
parquet de poursuivre les auteurs
d'atteintes particulièrement graves à
l'environnement
malheureusement de trop nombreux
exemples de catastrophe écologique que
je citais tout à l'heure nous concerne
las démunis les victimes envoyé à leur
solitude et à leur détresse et
condamnent d'état des territoires
parfois abîmés à jamais je redis le
scandale du chlordécone qui laisse
guadeloupe et martinique ce dans
certains endroits de leurs territoires
pollués pour des centaines d'années le
parc national des calanques souillée par
les boues rouges et nous avons tous le
souvenir de du littoral atlantique
polluer notamment par la dernière marée
noire de l'erika en 1990 doit-on s'en
tenir à l'arsenal juridique que nous
possédons actuellement nous proposerons
deux
d'inscrire le crime descossy dans ce
texte afin que la france puisse enfin
poursuivre des faits qui aujourd'hui
sont réprimés de manière presque
anecdotique au regard de leur gravité
certes rares les échos ci devraient être
consacrés comme tel et puisque nous
sommes réalistes nous vous soumettrons
des améliorations substantielles du
texte afin qu'ils puissent un tant soit
peu faire avancer la protection
d'environnement d'autres pays
merci trois amendements issus aux
communes 369 en amène bassar monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues la création d'un délit de mise
en danger de l'environnement figurent
parmi les recommandations de la mission
d'inspection conjointe ige j bar cgedd
au sein du rapport intitulé une justice
pour l'environnement d'octobre 2010 9 si
nous soutenons cette volonté la
rédaction proposée par le présente
arctique pose plusieurs problèmes
j'en citerai deux les faits poursuivis
doivent être subordonnés à la
caractérisation d'un au respect d'une
mesure individuelle de l'administration
cela conditionne donc l'efficacité d'une
telle mesure au renforcement des
contrôles administratifs seul
susceptible de caractériser le
non-respect de telle prescription
or la mission d'information sur lubrizol
a révélé la diminution importante de ses
contrôles sur les dix dernières années
autre exemple la plus l'appréciation de
la durabilité du dommage non survenu
devant en outre perdurer au moins 10 ans
dans le cas du naufrage du pétrolier
erika en 1999
les experts avaient estimé que le
dommage n'avait pas perduré plus de deux
ans ainsi l'une des plus grandes
catastrophes écologiques de ces trente
dernières années ne rentrerai pas dans
la définition de ce nouveau délit cette
rédaction est donc à la fois
juridiquement contestable car
possiblement contraire
l'objectif constitutionnelle
d'intelligibilité de la loi pénale et
scientifiquement inadaptée car
inopérable notre groupe propose ainsi
réécriture de cet article qui répondent
à l'objectif initial du projet de loi à
savoir créer une nouvelle infraction
droit pénal visant à réprimer des
comportements délibéré mettant grand
montage en danger l'environnement
indépendamment de la réelle réalisation
d'un dommage ou d'une mise en demeure de
l'autorité administrative mars s'est
jamais 4,72 à l'imprévu merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues cet amendement propose
une nouvelle rédaction de l'article 167
afin de renforcer le régime de sanctions
applicables à la mise en danger
délibérée de l'environnement par
transparence nous vous précisons qu'il
est inspiré des travaux de l'office
central de lutte contre les atteintes à
l'environnement et à la santé de la
population qui en février 2020 a rendu
un rapport proposant des modifications
législatives
il propose ainsi de réprimer les
comportements délibéré mettant gravement
en danger lors l'environnement et ce
indépendamment de la réalisation d'un
dommage ou d'une mise en demeure de
l'autorité administrative
nous ne retenons donc pas la notion
d'atteinte durable dans le temps de dix
ou sept ans comme le propose le
gouvernement ou les rapporteurs car nous
estimons que cette appréciation
subjective sera un frein à la bonne
application de la législation et je me
permets de faire une petite remarque à
ce sujet là
quand on regarde la pollution dues à la
marée noire de l'erika
je voudrais saluer le travail de tous
les bénévoles qui même au se sont mis en
danger au niveau de leur santé et toutes
les collectivités qui ont eu vrai sans
relâche pour faire disparaître un tant
soit peu les marques de cette pollution
et heureusement que nous n'avons pas
laisser tout en place en effet déterminé
alors une durée d'atteindre dans le
temps avant même que la dégradation soit
effective
aussi nous semble très difficile et
ouvre la voie à un champ d'être
d'interprétation très large qui
malheureusement ne risque pas d'aller
dans le sens de l'intérêt général mais
davantage de profiter à des intérêts
économiques privés
je remercie mercier 2342
manette wii merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre et chers collègues de
la rédaction de cet article une
excessive aux complexités le nombre de
verrous mise en place sur un peu
crédible son application est réduit
l'intérêt de cette réforme du droit
pénal de la mire nos mains qui était
pourtant très attendu à savoir la
création d'un délit de mise en danger de
l'environnement la portée de ce délire
est très limité à seulement quelques
infractions du code de l'environnement
alors que d'autres corps de sanctionner
les atteintes à l'environnement tels que
le code minier le code forestier ou le
code rural et de la pêche maritime
elle est limitée quant aux attentes
différents milieux physiques elle est
limitée par la nécessité de démontrer
que la teinte et durable père durant au
moins c'est encore le caractère durable
de l'infraction ne traduit pas la
gravité et reste pratiquement impossible
à déterminer
au moment de la constatation des faits
comme l'a démontré la sphère de l'erika
malgré la gravité et la durée de ce
désastre environnemental a duré environ
deux ans vraiment amendement propose
donc de transformer la circonstance
aggravante de mise en danger de
l'environnement un véritable délit de
mise en danger de l'environnement ne
serions pas opposé à prévoir des peines
moins élevés comme nous l'avions proposé
par le passé le cadre l'examen d'autres
textes première main ce gamin demain
supprime le recours au caractère durable
de l'infraction
deuxièmement il sanctionne toute
violation manifestement délibérée d'une
obligation particulière de prudence ou
de sécurité imposées par la loi le
règlement ou un acte administrative
indue est individuelle qui exposerait
l'environnement à une dégradation
substantielle
il permet ainsi d'intégrer toutes les
atteintes à l'environnement y compris
lorsque l'auteur méconnaît l'a dit les
dispositions d'autres codes que celui de
l'environnement
enfin il propose d'insérer ce nouveau
d'élite au sein du code pénal en
cohérence avec l'article 410 tirer 1 du
code pénal qui reconnaît l'équilibré du
milieu naturel et de l'environnement de
la france au titre des intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation quand même à
porter
mon avis sera le même pour les pour ces
trois amendements en réalité et la vie
sera défavorable puisque ce sont des
amendements qui crée un délit génériques
et autonome de mise en danger de
l'environnement contrairement à ce que
prévoit l'article
dans sa rédaction actuelle qui fait de
la mise en danger de l'environnement une
circonstance aggravante il n'est pas
souhaitable de créer pareil délit sans
évaluation préalable ni étude d'impact
il est nécessaire d'évaluer au préalable
la manière dont cet article sera
appliquée par les juridictions avant de
créer un délit autonome donc la vie pour
les trois amendements est défavorable
c'est même le ministre merci monsieur le
président tout d'abord juste un doigt
sur le crime descossy telles que ils
étaient explicites et par les différents
orateurs et différentes oratrice en
l'occurrence vous faites référence à des
des événements qui sont perpétrés un peu
partout dans le monde
quand vous parlez de la dernière de ce
qui s'est passé notamment au sri lanka
qui effectivement très grave
ça ne peut pas relever d'une juridiction
française s'est on est on voit bien que
là on est au niveau du droit
international et que on doit réussir à
créer ce crime d'ecaussinnes au niveau
international et c'est de l'action que
mène l'état aujourd'hui au niveau des
instances internationales pour qu'on
réussisse à avoir cette qualification
qu'ils soient opérés pour revenir aux
amendements en question donc c'est un
avis défavorable sur sur ces trois
amendements
pourquoi parceque il crée un délit
autonome de mise en danger
l'environnement sans référence à la
règlement appliqué à la réglementation
applicable à activités en cause et nous
préférons
rédaction de l'article 67 du projet de
loi tel qu'adopté à l'assemblée
nationale afin de circonscrire le champ
d'application de la mise en enjeux
d'environnement et de maintenir les
équilibres de cette nouvelle
incrimination
tout ça fait partie d'un ensemble pour
qui permet d'améliorer le droit de
l'environnement quand j'entends que le
droit de l'environnement doit être
améliorée c'est vrai et c'est pourquoi
nous avons mis notamment en oeuvre un
certain nombre de réformes comme la
création de parcs est spécialisée en
matière environnementale pour faciliter
traitement des procès verbaux
nous créons dans cette loi la
circonstance aggravante du non respect
d'une mise en demeure si mise en danger
de l'environnement dans l'article 67
nous mettons en place le délit de
pollution généralisée pour les
pollutions les plus graves nous
facilitons la reconnaissance de la
récidive en matière de pollution qui
permet de doubler des peines et nous
mettons aussi en place des éléments sur
le territoire
quand nous donnons à l'eau esb et des
prérogatives d'officier de police
judiciaire c'est aussi pour faciliter
justement la détection et le un meilleur
contrôle des atteintes à l'environnement
voilà quelques exemples qui montrent que
effectivement ce droit d'environnement
pendant longtemps été parent pauvre de
du droit en général et que nous mettons
tout en oeuvre pour que ce parent pomme
ne le soit plus merci madame la ministre
donc je vais mettre aux voix ces
amendements
j'ai eu deux demandes de scrutins
publics mais est-ce qu'il ya besoin d'un
scrutin public
moi je pense pas un prêt ville vous êtes
déjà pas mal intervenus mais bon je vous
redonne la parole à alléger
merci monsieur le président donc si j'ai
bien compris
certes c'est ces catastrophes donc j'ai
évoqué quelques noms ne sont pas arrivés
en france mais est ce à dire que rien ne
peut nous arriver de la sorte
sommes-nous à l'abri de tout enfin à mon
avis c'est irréaliste
gouverner c'est prévoir dès lors que ce
genre de catastrophe écologique qui ne
sont pas des catastrophes naturelles
existent ont déjà existé ailleurs dans
le monde et qui mettent en cause des
personnes ou des sociétés
nous ne sommes à l'abri de rien enfin
franchement je trouve que ce serait bien
de prévoir et d'avoir l'arsenal
juridique à même de pouvoir aider les
populations ou défendre notre territoire
contre ce genre de choses nous avons la
marée noire alors pour la marée noire
par exemple je dédie tout à l'heure
heureusement que nous avons eues les
bénévoles qui sont venus tout nettoyer
si on n'avait rien fait effectivement
serait dur et plus longtemps mais ça a
duré moins de 7 ans parce que tout le
monde s'est mis au nettoyage les
collectivités etc
donc il faut tenir compte de ces félins
sont des faits réels père collègues
n'ont jamais on voit l'amendement 369
avec un double avis défavorable qui et
pour qui et contre 6 s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté de 1472 avec deux avis
défavorables mais vote même vote il
n'est pas adopté de 1342 même vote
il n'est pas adopté quatre amendements
diffusion commune de 835 retirer
le 1933 monsieur l'abbé monsieur le
président madame la ministre charles
collègues
cette amende mais je me trompe là
le temps s'écoulant défendu
merci traite
il s'agit de d'améliorer la rédaction
actuelle de l'article 67
afin de rendre plus opérationnels afin
de le rendre plus les opérationnels cet
article vise à réprimer les
comportements qui font courir un danger
grave à l'environnement indépendamment
de la réalisation des ouvrages
l'esprit est plus que louable puisque en
matière environnementale
il est souvent complexe voire impossible
de réparer un dommage sanctionner les
comportements faisant courir un risque
grave à l'environnement pour prévenir
les atteintes est donc bien nécessaire
cependant cela a été évoqué l'article
prévoit pour cela que le dommage soit
grave et durable c'est-à-dire dure plus
de sept ans ce qui pose éminemment
problème on ne peut que très rarement
très rarement démontrer cette durée de
dommage d'autant plus lorsqu'on parle
d'une mise en danger et donc dans le
dommages potentiels
même dans le cas de dommages qui ont eu
lieu les conséquences des pollutions
pour l'environnement étant très complexe
à appréhender ce n'est que rarement
possible de pouvoir montrer une telle
durabilité pour l'erika on a montré
d'état des traces de polluants sur deux
ans pour lubrizol à l'orgue les
procédures sont encore en cours personne
ne peut actuellement déterminer avec
précision la durée de la teinte l'air
elodie lui fortement les polluants par
nature on ne pourra pas prouver cette
durée de 10 ans pour la pollution de ces
milieux on acte donc avec cet article
une protection de ces milieux plus
faible que celle des sols les milieux
aquatiques notamment sont pourtant
menacée de façon importante par les
pollutions
la commission a commencé à reconnaître
cette problématique en réduisant de 10 à
ces temps la durée
mais ce n'est pas encore suffisant de
plus ce qualificatif de durable n'est
pas en ligne avec le droit européen qui
emploie le terme significatif pour
qualifier les atteintes à lombia
l'environnement le droit de
l'environnement est déjà très complexe
et difficilement appliquer sur le
terrain
ce constat est partagé par tous cet
article ne vient donc pas améliorer son
efficacité
alors l'idée initiale était louable
l'amendement propose donc de substituer
les collectes les qualifs
les qualificatifs graf et durable par le
qualificatif grave et significatif jo
merci merci le 2180 madame la ministre
du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président c'est un
amendement qui vise à rétablir la
rédaction d'articles 67 dans sa
rédaction tel qu'adopté par l'assemblée
nationale en première lecture
il permet ainsi d'augmenter la peine
d'amendé encourues pour les
circonstances aggravantes de mise en
danger de l'environnement qui est de 200
mille euros la passe et à 300000 euros
ce montant mme appareils en effet plus
dissuasif et permettra de réprimer plus
efficacement ces comportements qui crée
un risque immédiat d'atteinte grave et
durable à l'environnement
je rappelle que non respect d'une simple
mise en demeure sans mise en danger de
l'environnement est déjà passée d'une
amende de 100000 euros
ensuite cet amendement permet de définir
les attentes durable comme celle
susceptible de durer au moins 10 ans au
lieu de sept comme prévu par la
commission
d'ailleurs juste on parlait tout à
l'heure de la chlordécone typiquement
voilà ce que c'est
les atteintes durable en général c'est
sur les sols est typiquement ce qui
s'est passé avec la chlordécone rendre
dans ce cadre le caractère durable des
atteintes à l'environnement pourrait
être établie grâce au recours à des
experts comme cela est déjà le cas pour
certaines infractions
cet équilibre a fait l'objet de
nombreuses discussions avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes c'est un équilibre
il permet de concilier une pénalisation
des comportements susceptibles de mettre
en danger environnement tout en assurant
une sécurité juridique des acteurs et
enfin juste madame prévis je rappelle
que suite à l'erika avait été votée dans
la loi et notamment et dans la loi sur
la biodiversité en 2016
la notion de préjudice écologique qui
avait d'ailleurs été travaillé par un
certain nombre de sénateurs
à l'époque la notion de préjudice
écologique qui est une notion absolument
essentiel parce qu'elle impose une
réparation des dommages une réparation
qui peut se faire en nature c'est à dire
on répare les dégâts ou si on ne peut
pas le faire en
en argent et vous préciser merci le 253
monsieur longuet oui merci monsieur le
président madame les ministres mes chers
collègues je suis très attentif comme
lorrain haut dé gamme signé j'avais le
sentiment qu'une durée d'observation de
dix ans était préférable à une durée
d'observation s'étend mais je ne demande
qu'à être convaincu si on explique les
choses
merci donc à mama entendeur les trois
amendements qui restent en discussion
oui pour le 1933 c'est un amendement qui
propose évidemment de ne pas retenir la
notion d'atteinte grave et durera pour
la remplacer par celle d' atteinte
significative
la commission a fait le choix d'abaisser
de trois ans le seuil à partir duquel
une atteinte est considérée comme
durable
cette évolution répond ben cheikh
collègues en partie à la préoccupation
des auteurs de cet amendement
en revanche il me paraît nécessaire de
conserver la notion d'atteinte grave
dans la mesure où il s'agit du
circonstance aggravante en cas de non
respect de prescriptions administratives
en matière d'installation présentant un
danger pour l'environnement
il est également nécessaire qu'un seul
puisse définir la notion le nombre
d'années à partir duquel une atteinte
est considérée comme durable afin de
limiter les divergences d'appréciation
d'une juridiction à l'autre et de ne pas
introduire de rupture d'égalité devant
la loi pénale en fonction du lieu de
consommation de l'infraction vous avez
compris l'avis est défavorable
l'amendement 2180 madame la ministre qui
est l'amendement du gouvernement
c'est un amendement qui propose de
revenir aux comptes sommes des peines
comme vous l'avez rappelé prévu par la
rédaction issue des travaux de
l'assemblée nationale la commission elle
a souhaité d'abaisser de 10 à sept ans
le seuil à partir duquel une atteinte
pouvaient être considérées comme
durables et de baisser en parallèle le
montant de l'amendé de 300 milles à
200000 euros
cet équilibre a paru plus conforme à
l'objectif recherché par cet article à
savoir la volonté de réprimer la mise en
dents
et de l'environnement de manière
réaliste dissuasif et proportionnée donc
l'avis est défavorable également
s'agissant chers collègues de
l'amendement 253 rectifié bis qui
demandent de revenir sur l'abaissement
évidemment de 10 à 7 ans du seuil à
partir duquel une atteinte pouvaient
être considérées comme durables sont
pour autant rétablir le montant de la
sanction pécuniaire et donc pour cette
raison là je vais vous demander cher
collègue de le retirer sinon la vie sera
défavorable également merci madame
ministre sur les deux autres amendements
site une demande de retrait au profit
d'un moment du gouvernement merci
monsieur l'abbé il est maintenue
maintenu monsieur longuet il est retiré
de 253 donc je veux mettre aux voix
le 1933 qui a reçu un double avis
défavorable commission gouvernement qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté je suis saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
l'est républicain sur l'amendement 2180
avec un avis défavorable de la
commission l'avis favorable du
gouvernement
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par atik 56
le règlement le scrutin est ouvert
les scrutins nombre de votants 329
suffrages exprimés 315 pour 23 contre
292 l'amendement et non adoptées
je mets souvent l'article 67 qui est
pour l'article 67 qui et contre qui
s'abstient
il est adopté article 68 deux
amendements en discussion commune de 370
madame benbassa monsieur le président
madame la milice le chers collègues le
nouveau délit prévu par cet article et
qui figurait aussi parmi les
recommandations de la mission
d'inspection conjointe et gj bar cgedd
au sein du rapport intitulé une justice
pour l'environnement d'octobre 2010 9
est également une demande de la
conférence nationale des procureurs de
la république
c'est dire la tente qu'ils suscitent
cependant la rédation actuelle pose
problème elle crée simplement trois
nouvelles incriminations sans qu'aucune
des nombreux inflation spécial
préexistantes ne soit remplacé ceci a
pour effet de complexifier davantage un
édifice pénale déjà difficilement
maîtrisable de plus contre l'article 67
la rédaction actuelle est inopérante du
fait de l'utilisation du qualificatif
durable l'atmosphère et les milieux
aquatiques et en deux environnements aux
fortes ou voile de dilution il sera
impossible de démontrer que les effets
d'une atteinte au zoo et ou à l'air sont
graves et durables c'est-à-dire qu'elle
perdure au moins dix ans comme l'exigent
pourtant le projet de loi enfin la carre
la caractérisation du nouvel du nouveau
délit général d'atteinte au milieu
physique nécessitera d'apporter la
preuve d'une violation manifestement
délibérée d'une obligation de prudence
ou de sécurité
excluant les fautes d'imprudence et de
négligence pourtant les plus nombreuses
c'est à mende montre
oppose donc de créer des infractions
général venant sanctionner de façon
effective la pollution de
l'environnement en créant un véritable
délit d'atteinte à l'environnement
revenant à la rédaction initiale
proposée en novembre 2020 par le garde
des sceaux et la ministre de la
transition écologique je vous remercie
et 2343 monsieur prénom est crié merci
monsieur le président ma vie mes chers
collègues de la vie des praticiens du
droit pénal l'environnement
la répression des atteintes à
l'environnement souffre d'un
éparpillement des infractions au sein de
différents codes ainsi que d'une
définition de l'infraction en fonction
du non respect une initiative s'est
séparé par pillement affaiblit la portée
du droit pénal d'environnement et sa
vertus préventives
un rapport de la mission conjointe du
gestionnaire de la justice qui s'appelle
justice pour l'environnement 2019
constate cette situation contribue à
brouiller la fonction sociale du droit
pénal de l'environnement qui apparaît un
cod la police administrative
il souligne que la réalisation actuelle
est trop souvent composés d'infraction
de grande technicité ils digèrent la
démonstration des résultats souvent
difficile à établir la création de vos
interlocuteurs dans la consternation est
pour rien dans la nuit que serait de
nature à répondre de tes aspirations
la réponse apportée par le projet selon
des saveurs a finalement peu
opérationnels pour réprimer l'atteinte
de bonta volontaires l'environnement la
douche
le conditions d'intentionnalité a été
critiqué parfois cet état a eu ce titre
on va les trouver ces infractions
l'auteur doit savoir que son
comportement était noyée position mais
est aussi consciente qu'un grave et
durable du dommage comme nous l'avons
déjà évoqué le caractère durable du
dommage est d'ailleurs très contestable
car il est réducteur de la réalité est à
l'environnement de surcroît la réaction
de l'articulation de la compétence de
noël qui n'a besoin de noms intelligente
et ce malgré la loi ne retient une
entreprise qui elle aussi doit on y voir
clair
le préservant nos banquiers porter bairi
gold pour but de sanctionner le fait de
provoquer une dégradation sujet les
environnements distincts à l'instar de
l'article 8 du projet de loi tel que
rédigé une infraction intentionnelle
l'impression non intentionnelle et en
retirant les mêmes quantum des peines il
nous faut de l'ambition dans ce domaine
pour emballer la lucrativité actuels
délits et crimes environnementaux
merci s'agissant de l'amendement 370 en
concertation avec la commission des lois
nous avons simplifié et rendus plus
lisibles les délits d'atteinte générale
au milieu physique qui concerne les
trois milieux eau air et sol en créant
deux grandes infractions lune non
intentionnelle et l'autre intentionnel
avec des peines plus sévères
l' équilibre ainsi trouvé permet une
meilleure lisibilité du droit et répond
aux critiques du conseil d'état qui
pointé un risque d'inconstitutionnalité
je suis arrivé c'est amendement propose
de ne pas retenir la notion d' effets
nuisibles grave et durable qui permet de
sanctionner la commission des
infractions les plus graves
il ne me paraît pas souhaitable dans un
premier temps et en l'absence d'étude
d'impact d'ouvrir trop largement le
champ des infractions susceptibles
d'être concernés par ce dispositif étant
donné notamment la sévérité des peines
prévues par ces nouvelles infractions
qui peuvent atteindre 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et 4 millions 4
millions et demi d'euros
donc la vie
défavorable s'agissant de l'amendement
1343 rectifier c'est un amendement qui
propose de codifier les atteintes
volontaires à l'environnement dans le
code pénal plutôt que le code de
l'environnement ce qui est sans
incidence sur la portée de ces
dispositifs
en outre les infractions proposés sont
plus généraliste et n'exclut pas
notamment les émissions dans l'air et
les opérations de rejet autorisé par
l'autorité administrative ce qui paraît
une précision indispensable pour ne pas
pénaliser les opérateurs de bonne foi
pour cette raison là chers collègues la
vie est aussi défavorable merci merci
monsieur le président concernant
l'amendement trois cent soixante dix
alors je dis tout de suite que s'il
reprend l'esprit de certaines mesures
que nous avions proposée avec monsieur
le garde des sceaux sur la lettre
il y a des grosses différences de
rédaction notamment sur la dernière
partie et c'est d'ailleurs ces
rédactions qui pose les difficultés et
notamment de nature constitutionnelle en
premier lieu il prévoit que les
infractions de pollution des eaux et des
sols s'applique
nonobstant la délivrance d'une
autorisation administrative ou d'une
décision administrative lorsque celle ci
est manifestement illégal
or cette notion d'autorisation
manifestement illégal était
excessivement imprécises et ne peut
constituer le support une infraction
pénale elle ne permet pas de
circonscrire avec précision le
comportement incriminé et à paris en
cela contraire au principe de légalité
des délits et des peines et en second
lieu la maman fait référence aux
éléments aux fonctions des écosystèmes
et ce qui est d'ailleurs aussi le cas
dans l'amendement 1343 rectifier or le
code de l'environnement ne contient pas
de définition de la notion d'écosystème
il s'agit d'une notion scientifique qui
désigne à la fois une étendue terrestre
marine la biodiversité qui réside à
l'environnement physique qui lui est
associée ainsi que leurs interactions un
écosystème n'est pas définie par son
étendue mais par ses caractéristiques
intrinsèques et la notion d'écosystème
ne peut constituer un support une
incrimination pénale des orc et est
susceptible de s'appliquer à des espaces
très réduits
ainsi elle ne permettrait pas de
ne réserver ces infractions caupenne
graves et durables cause atteinte grave
et durable pardon à l'environnement et
on aurait des infractions sur des
espaces très réduits qui serait par
conséquent susceptible d'être contraire
au principe de nécessité et de
proportionnalité des délits et des
peines garanti par l'article 6 de la
déclaration de 1789 donc pour ces
raisons je suis défavorable aux deux
amendements
merci donc jamais se voir l'amendement
370 avec un double avis défavorable qui
et pour qui est content qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adoptée jeu mais où va le
1343 avec deux avis défavorables qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il ne
pas adopter 17 amendements discussion
commune ne commence on parle 2180 madame
la ministre
merci monsieur le président c'est un
moment qui vise à rétablir l'article 68
dans sa rédaction issue de l'assemblée
nationale l'article 68 renforce
significativement la protection
judiciaire l'environnement à laquelle le
gouvernement est extrêmement attaché
en premier lieu il renforce la
répression des infractions applicables
en matière d'activités réglementé
lorsqu'elles ont entraîné les atteintes
graves et durables sur l'environnement
les peines sont alors portées à 5 ans
d'emprisonnement et un million d'euros
d'amendé
ce montant pouvant être portée jusqu'au
quintuple de l' avantage tiré de la
commission d'infractions
par ailleurs cet article crée un nouveau
titre au sein du code de l'environnement
dédié aux atteintes générale au milieu
physique afin d'appréhender les
atteintes graves à l'environnement dans
leur globalité
dans les cas les plus graves d'atteintes
intentionnelles graves et durables à
l'environnement les faits seront ainsi
réprimer d'une peine de 10 ans
d'emprisonnement et 4g des cinq millions
d'euros d'amendé au lieu de cinq ans de
prison et trois cent mille euros damende
a été actuel du droit et ces évolutions
permettront de réprimer alors juste
hauteur les atteintes à l'environnement
les plus graves j'en profite de monsieur
le président pour accélérer les choses
pour vous dire que donc sur les autres
amendements de la discussion commune
évidemment l'avis du gouvernement sera
défavorable c'est donc vous avez
présenté l'amendement et donnez votre
avis sur tous les autres 1478 président
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement vise à préciser la réduction
de la linea
12 tel qu issu des travaux de la
commission actuellement il précise que
les peines sont applicables applicable
en cas de violation manifestement
délibérée d'une obligation particulière
de prudence ou de sécurité prévues par
la loi ou le règlement
or la violation manifestement délibérée
est un concept créé par la loi dite
fauchon pour protéger les personnes
physiques
lorsqu'elles sont auteurs de fait dénuée
de causalité direct avec l'élément
matériel d'une infraction
volontaire il est important pour ne pas
mettre à bas l'édifice jurisprudentielle
qui s'est construit depuis cette loi que
ce concept ne soit pas étendu à la
violation en connaissance de cause qui
est l'expression adéquat pour désigner
le comportement visé par l'article l
231-1 du code de l'environnement
ce comportement est la mauvaise foi de
l'auteur qui ne souhaitent pas détruire
les écosystèmes mais économiser le coût
de la lutte contre les nuisances qu'il
connaît par ailleurs en général pour
concurrencer plus efficacement les
autres entreprises c'est l'objet du
présente avant nous merci chers
collègues le 1344 prénom riquier sa
collègue
il s'agit évidemment de robbie des
rigoles qui vise à supprimer le
caractère durable atteinte à la mire au
noir qui partit sur un tweet afin de
constituer l'infraction il aya une
cohérence de doha prouver que l'atteinte
d'un environnement dure depuis sept ans
dix ans dans la version du thé de
l'assemblée nationale alors que le
dirait presque vieille de six ans à
compter du jour où l'infraction a été
choriste
merci le 1935 mais le président la
ministre reconnaît là encore c'est un
amendement de repli par rapport à la
réécriture de l'article que nous
proposions dans le même esprit que les
amendements portés sur l'article 67 cet
amendement propose de remplacer le terme
durable par le terme significatif et de
supprimer la durée de ces temps qui
définit la durabilité
oui on insiste on l'a déjà évoqué lors
de la prise de parole sur l'article 67
mais en l'état avec ses dreads d'action
cet article ne permettrait pas de
sanctionner les comportements qui ont
mené à la catastrophe de l'erika pour
lubrizol tout le monde est d'accord sur
la gravité du dommage mais pour
l'instant
les experts ne sont pas encore en
capacité de définir sa durée on ne
pourrait donc pas sanctionné les fautes
qui ont mené à cette catastrophe sur la
base de cet article la création d'un
délit général d'atteinte à
l'environnement était très attendu mais
avec cet article ne répond pas l'enjeu
on peut donc s'interroger fortement sur
son utilité même si liste l'esprit
initial était bon on crée un nouveau
délit inapplicable ce qui complique si
complexifie encore le droit de
l'environnement et on l'a déjà aussi
précisé sur l'article 67
la commission européenne a édicté des
lignes directrices sur la définition du
dommage environnemental où elle propose
de le qualifier par un terme
significatif je me répète encore qui est
donc plus approprié que le terme durable
pour qualifier le dommage les attentes
environnementales ne sont condamnés que
très rarement et avec cet article
nous ne nous donnons pas les moyens de
changer la situation
et ce alors que l'urgence écologique est
devant nous si on veut faire de la
prévention
il faut véritablement que la loi soit
dur pour qu'il n'y ait pour qu'ils ne
prennent pas le risque de prendre des
risques
merci chers cola et 1433 me remercie
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues cet amendement vise
comme ceux de mes collègues à supprimer
la notion d'atteinte durable qui
pourrait rendre inopérant le dispositif
prévu à cet article en effet l'article
68 dans sa rédaction actuelle en
cumulant des critères de gravité et de
durabilité reviendrait à exclure les
atteintes graves dans la durée pour être
relativement courtes ou difficile à
caractériser dans le temps le caractère
subjectif de cette durabilité nous
interroge donc beaucoup et elle
impliquerait que nous disposions duty et
de connaissances suffisantes et adapté
lors de la survenance d'un aléa pour
être en capacité de la mesurer pire elle
reviendrait à exclure de son champ
d'application certaines catastrophes
écologiques qui ne sent qu'ils ne
s'étendent pas dans le temps et qui ont
pourtant marqué l'histoire de notre pays
je pense comme mes collègues au naufrage
de l'erika dans les experts
on établit que les atteintes n'ont duré
que deux ans et pour cause puisque
bénévoles et collectivités se sont
chargés de faire le nettoyage
or qui pourrait considérer ici que ce
dommage n'a pas eu d atteinte très grave
sur l'environnement si demain une
catastrophe similaire se produisait
serait-elle donc exclus du champ
d'application de cet article par cet
amendement nous souhaitons donc retenir
l'adjectif significatifs et non graves
qui selon nous est la seule condition
pour rendre les dispositifs opérant
merci de 1936 monsieur l'abbé m
madame la ministre collègues
cet amendement prévoit que
l'articulation de la nouvelles
dispositions prévues au présent article
ce qui a son importance pour la pratique
des enquêteurs et des magistrats
en effet cet article qui concerne la
pollution aquatique s'applique sans que
le parquet n'ait à faire la preuve d'une
intention de violer les normes
applicables ou encore de montrer une
intention de détruire ou endommager les
lieux les milieux pardon il convient
donc pour le respect des principes
constitutionnels de clarté et de
précision de la loi pénale de préciser
que cet article continue d'être a pris
un pli câble lorsque les faits ne
correspondent pas aux qualifications
prévues par l'article 68 du présente
projet de loi s'il 907 monsieur laménie
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre que l'aisne local est né à
l'initiative de notre collègue laurent
duplomb et de nombreux collègues
cet amendement vise à sécuriser le
dispositif de l'article 60 8 en
rappelant aussi les travaux de la
commission
ce texte risque de faire peser sur les
agriculteurs des risques juridiquement
particules particulièrement
important donc il est donc proposé par
cet amendement nos revenir au texte de
l'assemblée nationale tout en maintenant
la simplification opéré en commission
entre atteinte non intentionnelle et
intentionnel à l'environnement
tel est l'objet de cet amendement merci
le 1476 dans l'après ville merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
michelle collègues
cet amendement vise à renforcer les
sanctions applicables lorsque les
infractions sont commises par une
entreprise pour qu'une sanction soit
réellement dissuasive elle doit être
proportionnée par cet amendement nous
proposons donc d'établir une corrélation
entre le chiffre d'affaires d'une
entreprise et le montant de l'amendé à
appliquer concrètement nous proposons
que le montant maximum des maximales
pardon d'une sanction applicable à une
entreprise puisse être porté à 10% du
montant du chiffre d'affaires mondial
hors taxes en effet pour certaines
grandes multinationales dans le chiffre
d'affaires de s'exprimer en milliards
nous ne voyons pas comment une sanction
de 4 5 millions d'euros comme le prévoit
l'article 68 pourrait être dissuasive
alors certes l'article prévoit toutefois
que ce montant peut être porté au
décuple de l' avantage tiré de la
commission de l'infraction et cette
notion nous semble pouvoir prêter à
interprétation et une entreprise
pourrait très bien réussir à prouver
qu'elle n'a pas tiré davantage des
règles de telle ou telle infraction
nous pensons donc que l'essai au juge la
possibilité de fixer le montant d'une
sanction en fonction du chiffre
d'affaires de l'entreprise est la
solution la plus efficace
il était en effet courant de préciser la
manière dont la sanction doit se
calculer et ce qu'il faut retenir ou non
dans la comptabilité de l'entreprise
reconnue responsable de la commission
d'une infraction
encore une fois le quantum de la peine
n'est pas excessif
je rappelle à ce titre que la convention
judiciaire d'intérêts publics introduite
en 2016 est particulièrement efficace
depuis cette date permet au juge de
porter une amende à 30 % du chiffre
d'affaires par conséquent le porter à
10% ici nous paraît être tout à fait
raisonnable si nous n'inscrivons pas une
corrélation entre chiffre d'affaires et
le montant d'une amende encourus alors
les sanctions ne sommes pas réellement
dissuasives 2479 si vous pouvez
enchaîner ça serait bien cet amendement
disant péché que les autorisations
administratives julie jugées illégales
frauduleuse obtenu à posteriori à titre
de régularisation de confère un effet
exonère exonératoire de responsabilité
pénale à la personne poursuivie au titre
de l'article l 231-1 de l'environnement
créé par l'article 69 de ce projet de
loi
il s'agit donc ici d'éviter qu'une
personne en se prévalant d'une telle
autorisation puisse échapper à sa
responsabilité pénale et aux réparations
dont elle aurait dû être créancières en
quoi en cas de condamnation là encore je
suis étonné de l'avis défavorable de la
commission puisqu'il s'agit d'une
disposition de boussens en effet on ne
comprendrait pas qu'une entreprise
reconnue coupable d'une infraction qui
code de l'environnement puisse opposer
une autorisation irrégulière pour se
soustraire aux obligations qui en combat
qui incombe à toute personne physique ou
morale de réparer le dommage causé
alors si championnat en 1937 monsieur
l'abbé cieux le président madame la
ministre chers collègues dans le même
esprit que l'amendement défendu par mes
collègues et de nos amendements sur
l'article 67
il s'agit ici de ne pas conditionner
l'action judiciaire par l'action
administrative
il faut rappeler ici qu'en présence
d'une autorisation administrative
illicites
le juge pénal peut néanmoins condamné
condamné si cette autorisation s'avère
illicites cet amendement propose donc de
corriger la rédaction de l'article 68
afin de respecter ces principes
d'articulation entre autorités
administratives et autorités judiciaires
de 1474 malempré ville merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues cet amendement s'inscrit dans
la continuité des précédents et vise à
supprimer les références à une
définition de la durabilité des
atteintes pour nous imposer une durée
quelquefois de 10 ou de 7 ans rend
inopérant ce texte et serait même de
l'avis de certains experts con
r au droit européen nous tenons à
rappeler que caractériser une durée
nécessitera d'avoir les outils et des
connaissances nécessaires pour le faire
au moment de la survenance de l'atteinte
elle imposera également un travail d'
expertise dans les services de la police
de l'environnement du ministère public
ou les victimes directement ne
disposeront pas ensuite quand bien même
une expertise viendrait établir que les
atteintes sont susceptibles de dérives
le dur et puces c'est tout de dix ans il
sera aisé de la contredire
et ainsi en semant le doute d'éviter
toute condamnation
dans ces conditions nous proposons donc
de supprimer cette référence à la
durabilité d'une atteinte
merci le 250 de monsieur longuet oui
merci monsieur le président madame le
ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement a pour objet en ce qui
concerne le titre 6 dont la mise en
oeuvre va être extraordinairement
compliquée et dont la clarté sera sans
doute l'oeuvre d'une jurisprudence
soutenu durant plusieurs années à
différents niveaux y compris d'ailleurs
au niveau européen nous avons le devoir
absolu d'éclairer le travail de ceux qui
auront honte à reconnaître c'est la
raison pour laquelle cet amendement un
plus pour objet d'entendre une nouvelle
fois la conviction de madame notre
rapporteur qui s'exprime au nom de la
commission
et dont le texte sera je l'espère voter
mais on a besoin de clarté et madame la
ministre tout autant nous souhaitons ce
que vous le
le gouvernement l'article je crois 121-3
du code pénal indiquent qu'il y à nyc
remy dei sans intention de le commettre
or tel n'est pas le cas de l'immense
majorité des crimes ou délits que
qu'envisage le titre 6 et nous avons
pris à travers cet amendement deux cas
très précis
le premier essai celui d'une situation
qui a été réparé à l'initiative de celui
qu'il a originellement commis mais qui
n'a pas attendu un délai ce délai 7 ans
ou dix ans que vous évoquez va-t-il être
poursuivi de la même façon même si la
réparer correctement le dga qu'il n'a
jamais eu l'intention de commettre
délibérément mais qu'ils aient commis
fin qui est produit par son activité de
la même façon nous avons besoin d'avoir
plus de précisions sur l'intentionnalité
alors je sais que la jurisprudence dans
bien d'autres domaines reconnaît une
intentionnalité là où manifestement il
n'y en a pas mais une intentionnalité du
fait de la responsabilité inhérentes à
l'exercice d'une autorité et chefs
d'entreprise conducteurs d'automobiles
enfin personne n'a l'intention de mal se
conduire mais il se trouve que vous êtes
en situation de créer des dégâts mais je
souhaite que le gouvernement une rue
rapporteur puisse répondre à cet
amendement pour savoir exactement ce qui
nous pend au nez si vous me permettez
cette expression triviale de tous ceux
qui ont encore dans notre pays le
courage d'entreprendre et qui risque
d'être par ce titre 6 fortement
dissuasive
merci madame préville merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre chers
collègues
cet amendement vise à retarder le point
de départ de la prescription de l'action
publique en cas d'infraction aux cultes
ou dissimulé est au culte l'infraction
qui ne peut être connue ni de la victime
ni de l'autorité judiciaire et dissimulé
l'infraction dont l'auteur cherche à
empêcher par tous moyens la découverte
en matière environnementale il est
indispensable de pouvoir pousser le
point de départ de la prescription
dans la mesure où les dommages causés à
l'environnement peuvent être découverts
plusieurs années après la commission des
faits en cas d'infraction aux cultes ou
dissimulé envers ty en vertu de
l'article 9-1 du code de procédure
pénale le délai de prescription de
pourra de toute façon pas excéder douze
années révolues pour les délits et
trente années révolues pour les crimes à
compter du jour où l'infraction a été
commise tout merci merci 2345 monsieur
cabanel merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre et chers collègues le
présent amendement vise à supprimer
l'ajout de la commission sur lequel les
délits d'atteintes graves et durables à
mieux physique ne pourront plus être
poursuivi au delà de 12 ans à compter du
jour où l'infraction a été commise ce
qui n'est pas pertinent en matière
environnementale de la mesure où ce jour
est souvent complexe à déterminer
merci amendements identiques 1480 oui
c'est vu de l'urgence environnementale
et climatique à laquelle nous devons
faire face nous considérons qu'il n'est
plus possible aujourd'hui de négocier
avec la responsabilité qui est la nôtre
nous devons renforcer notre arsenal
juridique pour sanctionner les conduites
et les risques les atteintes à
l'environnement dans ce cas nous
estimons que l'inscription d'un délai de
prescription de 12 ans dans la loi ne va
pas du tout dans cet esprit d'un côté le
texte prévoit qu'une atteinte durable
sera considéré comme tel que si elle ne
dure plus de sept ou dix ans et de
l'autre on nous impose un délai de
prescription de 12 ans nous avons
sentiment que tout est mis en oeuvre
pour que le dispositif retenu soit le
moins contraignant est applicable
possible par cet amendement nous
demandons donc la suppression de ce
délai de prescription tel qu'il a été
introduit par le rapporteur de la
commission
merci aussi vous pourrez enchaîner avec
l'amicale 77
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement est dans la continuité des
amendements 1476 que nous avons défendu
tout à l'heure ils lisent à renfoncer
les sanctions applicables aux faits
prévus à l'alinéa 21 lorsque les
infractions sont commises par une
entreprise
nous estimons en effet indispensable
d'établir une corrélation entre le
chiffre d'affaires d'une entreprise et
le montant de l'amendé qui lui sera
appliquée afin de rendre les sanctions
réellement dissuasifs si enfin ce 180
malabo sans merci monsieur le président
le présente habite amendement vise à
préciser explicitement que la pollution
des eaux fait partie également les
atteintes graves et durables qui doivent
être sanctionnés merci merci maman
rapporteur merci monsieur le président
nous avons un grand nombre d'amendements
sur lesquels je vais donner l'avis de la
commission donc si vous m'autorisez je
vais les nommés au fur et à mesure pour
aller un petit peu plus vite donc pour
l'essentiel des amendements que nous
avons entendu la vie sera défavorable je
vais revenir sur les commentaires hormis
l'amendement 781 pour lequel l'avis sera
favorable et l'amendement 907 rectifier
pour lequel je vais demander la sagesse
du sénat
donc je vais comment je vais donner
quelques commentaires je vais peut-être
pas tous les reprendre chers collègues
ne m'en veuillez pas mais ils sont très
nombreux
je vais reprendre quelques uns dont
l'avis est défavorable je vais commencer
par celui du gouvernement madame la
ministre qui est l'amendement 2181
l'avis est défavorable car cet
amendement propose le rétablissement de
l'article tel qu'issu de l'assemblée
nationale la commission n'y est pas
favorable dans la mesure où c'est
rédaction n'a pas répondu de manière
satisfaisante aux critiques juridiques
soulevées par le conseil d'état est
rétabli la notion d'éco side et nous
venons de voter
avant d'autres dispositions qu'il est
préférable de réserver aux crimes
susceptibles d'être jugés par des
juridictions pénales internationales la
rédaction proposée source de complexité
en distinguant les milieux et en ne
retenant pas une ligne de partage clair
et univoque entre les infractions non
intentionnelle et celles commises de
façon intentionnelle pour les autres
alors il ya différents
différentes demandes mais tout revienne
sur l'écriture de ce qui a été proposé
par la commission
donc je vais peut-être puisque monsieur
longuet chers collègues nous avaient
interpellé un peu plus spécifiquement
donner la raison pour laquelle la vie
également de votre amendement est
défavorable vous vous demandez le
rehaussement du seuil des effets
nuisibles donc à 10 ans pour un peu les
mêmes raisons qu'on avait évoqué à
l'occasion de votre amendement à
l'article 67 la csé en concertation avec
la commission des lois que nous avons
trouvé que l' équilibre proposé par
l'écriture de
du texte de la commission est le
meilleur et c'est la raison aussi pour
laquelle la vie est évidemment
malheureusement défavorable en
l'occurrence pour le l'amendement pour
lequel je vais me ranger à la sagesse du
sénat
il s'agit donc du numéro 9 107 rectifier
c'est un amendement qui propose de ne
pas retenir le délit générique de
pollution des sols adopté par la
commission mais de le rattacher aux
prescriptions administratives relatives
à la gestion et à la prévention des
déchets cette formulation permet
d'extraire les activités agricoles du
champ des infractions portant atteinte
grave et durable à la qualité des sols
s'il convient comme le souligne l'auteur
de cet amendement de ne pas soumettre
les agriculteurs à touriste
d'incrimination abusive la protection
des sols contre les atteintes graves et
durables nous paraît tout autant
légitimes et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vais me ranger à votre
sagesse pour l'amendement 781 qui vient
d'être défendu par notre collègue madame
gosselin c'est un amendement comme elle
l'a dit propose tout simplement de
précisiez de préciser que la pollution
des eaux fait également partie des
atteintes graves et durables qui peuvent
être sanctionnés donc très naturellement
l'avis est favorable
merci merci ma porte madame la ministre
donner son avis mais elle veut en
rajouter monsieur le président pour pas
rallonger mais je voulais répondre
aussi nathan longue et monsieur le
ministre sur l'intentionnalité le code
de l'environnement et prévoit déjà des
délits pour pollution par négligence par
exemple l'article l de 116 tirs et 6 du
code sur les pollutions des eaux
cependant ici l'intention du
gouvernement est de mieux sanctionner
les cas les plus graves et notamment au
regard de leur caractère intentionnel
dont on est vraiment sur une action
intentionnelle sur une volonté délibérée
de nuire à l'environnement et quand vous
parlais tout à l'heure de ceux qui
veulent entreprendre dans notre pays
moi je suis aussi très attentive à ce
qu'il puisse entreprendre l'esprit vivre
l'esprit léger et donc même dans le cas
qui est prévu dans l'article précédent
sur la mise en danger de l'environnement
c'est tout simplement par non respect
des règles c'est à dire que ce sont des
personnes qui agissent alors que leur
activité n'est pas autorisée donc ils le
font ils ne savent qu'ils le font et que
ce n'est pas autorisé ou alors parce
qu'ils ont reçu des mises en demeure qui
ne respectent pas donc ce n'est pas ça
ne peut pas arrivé par hasard et donc il
faut vraiment rassuré les chefs
d'entreprise
un chef d'entreprise qui fait son
travail normalement n'est évidemment pas
mis en difficulté par cette
réglementation est cette législation
je vais mettre aux voix l'amendement
2180 du gouvernement j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public
monsieur l'abbé par rapport à ce que le
disait notre collègue gérard longuet
tout à l'heure sur la dissuasion alex
prix à l'esprit d'entreprise
effectivement il faut dissuader de
prendre des risques
par contre inciter les entreprises et
ceux qui ont l'esprit d'entreprise ils
ont et il y a des orientations nouvelles
pour l'entreprise pour les entreprises
qui vont permettre justement de nous
remettre debout au niveau planétaire
merci chers collègues non je j'ai été
saisi
scrutin public par le groupe union
centriste sur un amendement 2180 avec un
avis défavorable de la commission en
avis favorable du gouvernement
il va être possibilité au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par atik 56
du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
nombre de votants 3 129 suffrages
exprimés 280 pour 0 contre 280 le lavoir
nous on n'a pas été adopté donc nous
poursuivons avec le 1478
deux avis défavorables qui et pour qui
et contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 1344 deux avis défavorables
qui et pour qui est content qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 1935
deux avis défavorables pied pour qui et
contre le vph bien la main les chers
collègues qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 1473 deux avis défavorables
même vote même vote
il n'est pas adopté le 1936 deux avis
défavorables même vote même vote il
n'est pas adopté de 1907 un avis de
sagesse de la commission à l'avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre
mes chers collègues on va recommencer
qui et pour kippour qui est content
pardon
je
qui soutient il n'est pas adopté le 1476
deux avis défavorables qui et pour qui
et quand on prend qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le 1479 deux avis
défavorables est moque même pas adopté
de 1937 deux avis défavorables mais
votent pas adopter le 1474 deux avis
défavorables même vote
il n'est pas adopté de 252 et retirer le
1480 deux avis défavorables même veut
pas adopter le 1345 et le 1481 deux avis
défavorables même vote même vote il
n'est pas adopté le 1417 deux avis
défavorables
même pas il n'est pas adoptée et le 780
lui falloir de la commission à la vie
des faveurs du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
[Musique]